When I was young, games were developed only by big companies.
Now any two friends can meet together at leisure and develop games.
The Balloons was one of the first great games we developed,
It is a classic balloons game.
It was the first thing everyone said
It is difficult and impossible, not fun for users.
Although we have an audience,
But not asking for comments hurt us a lot.
We first have to simplify things and make them clearer,
Growth will then become easier.
One day, we had the idea of ​​developing a cat and piano game.
Joe thought, "What if you were a cat,
Going down and preparing you a small gift? "
We said, "This is a simple idea, and it may work."
"KleptoCats" is a virtual pet
You will not need to bear any kind of responsibility.
The game is very easy, where you will find a cat and an empty room.
Just tease her and ask her to leave.
"I'll be back soon," she says.
Then come back with a surprise.
To encourage players to continue playing,
We try to improve the sources of fun and the aspects that make the games interesting.
We believe it at times
When you make a surprise gift for you, the game offers a lot of emotions.
It is a kind of gifts offered by Gasha machines,
Where you get a gift you do not know what.
We have a very close relationship with users.
We read all their comments, and everything they tell us.
We always take them into consideration.
We launch games on Android first
Because it provides us with a platform for experimental use.
KleptoCats 2 is part of the beta platform,
Which helped us a lot because fans of the game liked them
Participation in that process.
Where they feel close to us when developing the game.
I remember we are at some point
We argued about any better icons.
We designed a symbol that we liked but did not like very much.
We decided to use the A / B test on the Store ...
When we did the tests between the different symbols
We've seen an app download increase of 30%.
We continue to expand our team to help us develop more games.
We plan to introduce "KleptoDogs" which are similar
"KleptoCats" but with the use of dogs.
Our audience asked for it, to see what would happen.
I think the hardest side and the most fun
For developers in Latin America when launching games,
Is the process of launching the game itself.
Continue developing games.
Do not stop developing games and do not take too long.
You do not need to develop an excellent game.
You will gradually learn from each and every feedback you receive
Your efforts will ultimately lead you to success.